Speaker 1: in the lighter news, because
it can't always be doom and gloom
and anger and vitriol and resentment toward
the other side. And they're anti democracy.
Remember this tweet from Elon Musk back in July
12th? Twenty twenty one. Those who attack SpaceX
maybe don't realize that SpaceX
represents hope for so many people.
Listen, say what you will about Lily. Elon Musk.
I have said a lot. I am not his biggest fan. I
don't think he is an existential threat, though.
This news is hilarious. Elon Musk to launch a
satellite. How about this? Keep that in mind.
Keep that tweet in mind as I read this story
that the people who attacked SpaceX maybe don't
realize that SpaceX represents hope for so many
people. Elon Musk to launch a satellite that
will beam advertisements into space. The venture
is a combined effort between Canadian technology
startup, Geometric Energy Corporation and SpaceX.
So SpaceX doesn't just represent hope. It also
represents advertising, which is hilarious because
this is about as low tech as it gets. It sounds
a Canadian technology startup will be partnering
with Elon Musk's SpaceX X to make SpaceX
advertisements a thing of the future. According to
a report by Business Insider, Samuel Reid, the CEO
and co-founder of Geometric Energy Corporation,
Getsy told the outlet that the company is working
to create a satellite called CubeSat. Real Cool.
One side of the CubeSat will be used to
promote arts excuse me ads, art and logos.
People and companies will be able to pay to place
their ads there by buying pixels on the display
screen with cryptocurrency. The GSA is planning
on launching CubeSat into space via one of
Musks Musk. Musk is SpaceX Falcon nine
rockets, which will release it into orbit
in space before the rocket heads to the moon.
Big news. All right. Here's where it gets just
Sheff's kiss. Hilarious, Reid said. Reid said
a selfie stick will be attached to the CubeSat
filming the display screen and
allowing people on Earth to watch it,
allowing people on Earth to watch it on
a live stream through YouTube or Twitch.
So if you thought this was going to
be like a massive a massive screen,
like a billboard in space that you can see from
Earth, it's not that it's a selfie stick with
a camera pointing back at it and you're going to
have to go to YouTube to actually witness the ads.
So, yeah, many people don't
realize that space represents hope.
Thanks for joining me, you guys. I'm
Jesse Dolma, sitting in for David Pakman.